everybody we're back you know I think
reflecting on the last 16 seasons if
there's one thing our show has come to
represent for people its professionalism
I believe we get the job done we we do
it right every time almost believe it or
not over the years sometimes
occasionally things have gone wrong
we're not perfect
sorry to shock it here's the proof this
is a collection of moments where quite
honestly things did not go according to
plan and sort of screwed up and only a
way our show can screw it up enjoy on
your mark get set go
[Music]
that that guy shot his wig off
[Applause]
this is a red kangaroo found in
Australia and actually this is kind of a
bad time to bring a kangaroo I did this
meeting see
[Applause]
we couldn't afford to put a top on that
box
I want to mention something fall TV
shows we're back on the Internet
swear to god we've been doing this show
for over fourteen years I have never
heard this sound before but everyone
stay calm
what is that all about Jeff do they know
we're taping
[Applause]
[Music]
ah yes my child
you don't you've been drinkin guy Arnold
come down your scar is falling off Oh
Arnold's I
[Applause]
you're man enough to enjoy your skulls
yeah let's examine exactly what happened
he goes and we've seen where the problem
is it's up and then kick and then you
know what I read and when I you know you
listen to and I love listening to music
and Friday I swear to God I don't know
what the hell that is if someone's mic
on backstage but why did a man's voice
just say now that's a good Friday and
they're pre recording it while we're
doing a show now what kind of crappy
show is this
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right I think that covers everybody
so let's move on I am the aqua king of
gods a master of the ocean every
creature of the CEO bathes me my power
is virtually limitless apparently not
your power of speech all right I think
we should move on because put this Chi
okay
[Applause]
you know the budget cuts have hit our
lighting department particularly hard we
no longer can afford to repair our
broken light fixtures which is a problem
because that's going to be it's gonna
fall any time now cuz that's how we
rehearsed it someone Falls I well I just
thought of another budget cut in it
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You trillion bus that was Jack
McBrayer in that box after all thanks to
him
let's dummy more show coming I'm just a
second we'll be right back